[Music]
hey what's going on welcome back and
happy new year hot ones fans this is
shawn evans and it seems like just
yesterday we closed out 2021 with the
bang from tom holland and his wing eight
meltdown onto bomb to santa gordon
ramsay and his giant sack of spicy food
antidotes we couldn't stay separated
forever we missed you way too much i
know it's a short break but we had to be
back for the new year the new season and
of course new sauces so settle in turn
your phones to silent and get ready for
the season 17 scoville symphony but
first a little off menu item dom sauce
me huh
hot ones junior the green
to our knowledge the first ever hot
sauce for kids is now available in
getting rave reviews from all ages
with a blend of jalapenos green apple
and banana it's the super mild you never
knew you needed in your life whether
you're a kid or you're just someone
looking for more flavor and a little
less heat hot ones junior for kids or
one of the new super mild did we invent
a genre i guess only time will tell all
right dom back to the sauce and back to
the lineup because we're beginning our
ascent up mount scoville and we begin at
base camp with a familiar friend the
classic
after a nice cameo from garlic fresno
last season the classic the classic is
back like it never left the one spot
there's something oddly comforting about
the classic returning to the head of the
table the number one spot the classic
the classic welcome back old friend all
right speaking of old friends at the
number two spot are canadian buddies
from dawson's
dawson's has cooked up a cedar smoked
garlic hot sauce that will warm our
guests through the depths of winter with
a smoky woody flavor and a hit of savory
garlic
the habaneros will also heat up our
guests this is a very hot number two if
you watched the show you've probably
heard me in the past like this is a hot
six this is a hot three this season a
very hot number two so expect some
fireworks in the front half a little
front half line up psychological warfare
here in the two spot all right number
three another return maker clark and
hopkins
clark and hopkins dreamed up calabria
while traveling in europe sweetness from
tomatoes and just a dash of mushroom
powder it set the stage for calabrian
chilies to transport you straight to
italy
[Music]
all right moving on to number four and
like with wine sometimes with hot sauce
you just have to say to yourself this
label it looks way too good not to try
does the phoenix have very colorful tail
feathers is it rising from the flaming
ashes of its predecessor or does it just
have some very spicy flatulence
either way angry goat keeps it just as
interesting inside the bottle with a
unique mix of cantaloupe and ginger
that's right melons in hot sauce a hot
sauce trend in 2022 you heard me call it
right here all right to the halfway mark
already and just like in the lead-off
spot we have another sauce reclaiming
its rightful place in the lineup say
hello once again to los calientes rojo
a bit of smoke a bit of sweet apricot a
touch of earthy cumin and just the right
amount of habanero to set the stage for
back half destruction and speaking of
the back half take a look at the number
six sauce queen majesty if you've been
watching us since the the day one the
blair's mega death sauce with liquid
rage the hot ones mixtape era then you
know that i love queen majesty sauces
the scotch bonnet and ginger i'm on
record saying it's my favorite hot sauce
of all time and this sauce right here
the cocoa ghost
an example of what i love about queen
majesty
cocoa powder and ghost peppers mingle
and menacing matrimony in a gingery
warmth gives way to a legit kick that's
sure to leave some flared nostrils in
its wake at the number six spot long
live the queen all right moving on to
number seven and we have a newcomer to
the table
13 angry scorpions jekyll and hyde
straight out of australia is bringing
scorching hot barbecue vibes with its
own blend of brown sugar and intense
scorpion peppers
this is also the part of the show where
well-mannered very experienced highly
media trained celebrities turn into a
raving lunatic so the jekyll and hyde
thing just seemed too fitting to pass up
here in the seventh spot all right on
number eight i know that there are some
of you probably just opened the video
check to see is the bomb still in the
eighth spot
new year
new tiers same to bomb at number eight
as salma hayek would say there's just
pain no pleasure like a bad lover it's
been described as poison i've said that
i do not condone it i do not endorse it
i do not recommend it but it's here the
bomb holds its place in the 8th spot if
you haven't yet watched editor collins
compilation of the best bomb reactions
of 2021 i highly recommend checking it
out as little pregame for season 17
and then moving on to number nine it is
pucker butt pepper company's extra mean
green and you know what that means that
means back to back smoking head curry
concoctions to close out the lineup
usually you don't expect verde sauces to
be scoville chart toppers but leave it
to our favorite mad scientist chili
farmer to flip the script you're talking
about a blend of apollo and pepper x
peppers here in the nine spot and
speaking of apollo it's the gold label
the last dab apollo riding again to
close things out at number 10.
and then there was one the gold bottle
the giant slayer the king of kos you
don't have to if you don't want to but
most people do anyways and there you
have it it's the season 17 hot ones hot
sauce lineup ain't she a butte as you
know if you've been around the block a
couple times when the hot sauce reveal
comes that means the season premiere is
just around the corner and hot ones
returns with our new cast of characters
on
january 20th that's right january 20th
hot ones rides again for season 17.
thank you so much for sticking around
with us now for
seven years 17 seasons hundreds of
episodes
as long as you care
i am going to sit here and eat the
hottest scorching hot chicken wings in
the history of the earth
that is my pledge to you thank you so
much hot fan
i almost i almost
almost just straight took
we'll see you again
january 20th
amazing